we did battle royale airsoft a while ago
I was really popular and I will tell you
right now that shoot was a total [ __ ]
show what are the things that a kid or a
group of kids would need to do plate up
gar something it was really really funny
having a gunfight with these two other
people when shoot a guy in low and they
go down behind cover you see them
crawling away and then we know that what
we see the partners are running towards
them behind cover like they're gonna
wrestle brusha brusha brusha come around
the corner and he's like and then we
start looting him then we got burger
ball we're looting it's like a classic
classic about reality so maybe we're
like if you want do your own air sauce
pumpkin game there's a couple tricky
things to deal with we did battle royale
airsoft a while ago to having all these
issues it's like this is terrible like
edited the video it turns out it's an
excellent video but it's amazing it's
really like action-packed because there
are so many people spread throughout the
map there's all these different stories
going on those different moments there's
all these things you can pull from so
even though my individual gameplay
wasn't the most exciting because there's
all these other people who are doing all
their own things cutting back and forth
this like really exciting I think we
learned a lot from that and we did this
mode which is a little more exciting we
actually defined the guns I hope I
supposed having like a gun in the bag
randomly you do you don't start with a
gun I don't know you start with nothing
we all spread out we had duo's we
noticed that in the battle royale I saw
people tended to like meet someone and
be like hey can I trust you or let's
work together and like they would do
this whole traitors truce thing where
they like I promise I won't kill you as
long as you help me win so to eliminate
that we're like we're just gonna do duo
so you have partners you have
interactions communication that's
supposed to use silently running around
or hiding and have that teamwork which
is cool it is it's a co-op it's
two-player co-op and one of you get down
you can crawl and you can get read by
your teammates which I got res multiple
times I'd also raised a couple times so
it adds that whole element we're like if
you're down you're not immediately out
of the game you're your teammate can
still come and get you in the game you
can get a shot all the time it's
generally an Aris office one shot kills
we did what we call wingding rules get
wing get hit in the arm with leg you get
one more hit and then you're down the
chest or the head then you're instantly
Ben if you're wearing armor you can pick
up level 2 armor that gave you one extra
hit issues that start to rise from that
is first off instinctively when you get
hit oh yeah I don't need to like pause
and like wait where did I get hit oh I'm
okay
and then like you run away another
person just shot you when other heads
are dead and they left also when you
where though with level 2 armor it's
kind of baggy on you so when you get hit
you barely feel it in the game the guns
are so accurate that it makes sense that
it takes so many around sit down a
gallon but airsoft the guns are so
inaccurate and your have so many few
rounds and like your bb's are kind of
like this outside they're kind of going
like everywhere you can't expect
actually land that many hits at a
distance so I think like the one shot
two shot thing it kind of like balances
it a little bit I think the wingding
will rules worked well we're just so not
used to using those rules like it's been
a really long time since we implemented
those rules it was a freshman at once
memories he's like cruel like what's
wrong oh yeah there's this lot of
challenges I feel a location is huge you
have to have almost somewhere big enough
everyone can't just see each other at
the beginning of the game buildings to
put guns in because give guns
technically aren't so supposed to be
laying out they're supposed to be inside
buildings what was placed home called
wild lands wild lands air side she's
pretty big park how big was the field
that you guys played about half a mile
by half a mile the biggest hurdle for
filming airsoft battlegrounds is keeping
the circle consistent and like actually
implementing the circle properly we
ended up using a method where we just
chopped off sections of the map the map
is really large but there's all these
separate sub Maps within it little areas
that are very specifically their own
areas everyone saw we just chopped those
out it's very loose so it's not like
people were in the dead zone still
fighting hard to tell then I answer the
radio that is probably the biggest issue
I think or like like setting up be like
oh we have this much time we should go
now we have to get to the circle now so
we can like kill people as they're
trying to run in but you don't need air
you're in real life yeah I honestly
having someone kind of DM the game kind
of like overrun the game who's not
playing who's just like maybe like in a
watchtower watching or just observing
having them kind of coordinate
everything would be super helpful what
we did is we took a Google Earth image
we drew out the area we should do next
time is actually have quadrants set up
text it to everybody who's playing the
game so they have it on their phone and
then just
have them look at it before the game so
everyone gets familiar with the map so
even without looking at their phone they
counter sailing all right this is the
south side of map this is kind of a cut
off area so at the end of the day as
long as everyone is just generally
moving towards a final area as long as I
kind of know like all right you should
kind of head towards this area it'll
work and having it one of radios it's
really important I think it worked out
pretty well we learned a lot the looting
is actually really fun reading a minute
like unarmed and then you find a gun
feels like you justify treasure it's a
lot of games where I started and I had
such a class of law I started and I ran
I found in 1911 a rose yes pistol run
over next by a shotgun like ok cool and
I grabbed the fan I'm like this is such
a classic beginner 911 shotgun it's
really fun the looting processes it adds
this whole other element and randomness
to the game if you won't play your own
battlegrounds game you're going to need
a lot of guns they don't have to be nice
guys so you can get a bunch of
Springer's scatter them through the
field but you're going to need a lot of
way that's great need some space to play
it really at the end of the day you're
gonna need a group of friends who are
willing to roleplay just a little bit
it's almost like a little bit like a D&D
game exactly it's like half a play
that's all because if you won't play it
really competitively it's easy to change
it's easy to cheat it's easy to like oh
I'm in the boundary I'm not in the
boundary I've you know if you get too
caught up in the details if you're gonna
like get uptight about you like a friend
like oh you stepped other boundary
you're dead you're gonna get caught up
in that kind of stuff you're not gonna
have a good time it's really more about
laughing at me the way the winds of
Fortune change and find a nice gun you
kill somebody else who has a knife you
know or something like that and you
leave a body then you get shot in the
back while you're losing the body and
you know you want to be a little laugh
at those moments as always having fun
because you're just playing a video game
and so all the stuff we've been talking
about the first episode came out today
so if you guys want to watch it check
out node it's a gaming channel where
this guy's on it I wanted to make
Samsung also Sam's okay we make cool
airsoft videos where we copy video games
and battlegrounds our favorite game so
it only makes sense that we played it
but I think the wait was worth it so
yeah you guys should check it out
[Music]